>> Dana: UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY REFUSING TO BACK DOWN
DESPITE RUSSIAN MILITARY ATTACKS
ON HIS COUNTRY.
ZELENSKYY REVEALING HIS LOCATION
IN THE WAR TORN CAPITOL KYIV AND
SENDING THIS DEFIANT MESSAGE.
>> I THINK HERE IN KYIV AT
BANCOVA STREET.
I DON'T HIDE AND I'M NOT AFRAID
OF ANYONE.
I WILL STAY HERE AS LONG AS IS
NECESSARY TO WIN IN OUR
PATRIOTIC WAR.
>> Dana: AND AS PRESIDENT
ZELENSKYY BEGS FOR MORE HELP
ANNOUNCING IT IS PRIORED TO
DEPLOY MIGHT GO 29 FIGHTER JETS
AT AN AIR BASE IN GERMANY GIVING
THE US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TRANSFER THEM TO UKRAINE.
THE STATE DEPARTMENT SAYS THEY
WERE CAUGHT OFF-GUARD.
LET'S GO TO MIKE THE LEAD IN
UKRAINE.
GOOD EVENING, MIKE.
I THINK IT'S JUST AFTER MIDNIGHT
THERE.
>> IT IS.
AND POLAND WAS RELUCTANT TO MAKE
THIS MOVE FEARING THAT SLIPPERY
SLOPE TO COMBAT OF EAST VERSUS
WEST IF THEY WERE TO DONATE THE
AIRCRAFT AND SUDDENLY THERE CAME
THIS ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY THAT
POLAND WOULD DONATE ITS FLEET OF
MIG 29S WITH THE PROMISE THEY
WOULD BACK FILL THEM WITH F 15S.
US OFFICIALS SAY THEY WERE BLIND
SIDED BESIDE THE ANNOUNCING.
HERE'S THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
>> WHEN I SAW THAT ANNOUNCEMENT
BY THE GOVERNMENT OF POLAND AS I
WAS LITERALLY DRIVING HERE
TODAY, TO MY KNOWLEDGE, IT
WASN'T PRE CONSULTED WITH US
THAT THEY PLANNED TO GIVE THESE
PLANES TO US.
BUT, AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN
HAVING CONSULTATIONS WITH THEM
FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS NOW ABOUT
THIS REQUEST FROM THE UKRAINIANS
TO RECEIVE THEIR AIRCRAFT.
>> NOW THE UKRAINIANS WOULD
WELCOME THIS DEVELOPMENT BECAUSE
THEIR PILOTS ARE TRAINED TO FLY
THE MIGS AND THERE SEEMS TO BE A
MECHANISM THROUGH WHICH THE
POLISH GOVERNMENT CAN PUT IT
BACK ON NATO BY PUTTING THE
PLANES BACK INTO THE AIR FORCE
BASE.
BUT, AGAIN, THE UKRAINIANS HAVE
REQUESTED TIME AND TIME AGAIN
FOR A NO-FLY ZONE OR THE WAY THE
UKRAINIANS PUT IT, TO CLOSE THE
SKY.
THEY FEEL IT WOULD VERY -- IT
WOULD BE A STEP TOWARD
EQUALIZING THIS FIGHT.
IN FACT, ONE OF THE REFUGEES
THAT I SPOKE WITH YESTERDAY SAID
THEY VERY MUCH WANT TO CLOSE THE
SKIES BECAUSE IF YOU CAN TAKE
THE FIGHT TO THE GROUND, HE
SAID, WE'D KILL THEM LIKE RATS.
GUYS, BACK TO YOU
>> Dana: MIKE TOBIN THANK YOU
STAY SAFE AND SEE YOU LATER
TONIGHT I'M SURE.
JESSE WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT
THIS MOVE BY THE POLS?
>> Jesse: POLS REALLY TRIED TO
FORCE THEIR HAND, DIDN'T THEY?
I DON'T THINK THEY WANT THEIR
HANDS DIRTY BUT DO WE WANT OUR
DIRTY?
WHY TRANSFER THEM TO TECHNICALLY
AN A US AIR BASE IN GERMANY.
IT SEEMS CONVOLUTED BUT AGAIN
THIS I IS TRYING TO DRAG
AMERICAN INTO THIS.
THIS IS A NATO ALLIANCE,
DEFENSIVE ALLIANCE, LET'S NOT
EXPAND IT AND PLAY A GAME OF
CHICKEN WITH SOMEBODY WHO HAS
NOTHING TO LOSE.
PUTIN HAS NOTHING TO LOOSE.
ECONOMY IS CRATERING.
THIS IS HIS LAST GASP HERE.
THIS IS ALL OR NOTHING FOR HIM
AND WHY WOULD YOU PLAY CHICKEN
WITH SOMEONE LIKE THAT?
HE'S JUST GOING TO GO ALL OUT SO
IT'S INCREDIBLY RISKY.
I WOULD JUST LIKE TO BE A LITTLE
MORE MEASURED.
YOU GIVE THEM THINGS HERE, WE
GIVE THEM THINGS THERE, RAMP UP,
SEE HOW RUSSIA REACTS.
BECAUSE IF WE JUST START SENDING
AIR CRAFTS INTO THAT WAR ZONE,
WHAT HAPPENS IF THAT PILOT
ENGAGES A RUSSIAN ANTI AIRCRAFT
BATTALION DOWN ON THE GROUND.
SO WE'RE TAKING OUT RUSSIAN ANTI
AIRCRAFT IN RUSSIAN PROPER OR
BELARUS?
THAT'S HOW YOU HAVE TO DEFEND
YOURSELF IN THE SKY.
I'M AFRAID OF THIS SPIRALLING
OUT OF CONTROL.
WE WENT IN THE ENTIRE COLD WAR
WITH NEVER HAVING TO GET INTO A
SHOOTING WAR WITH THE RUSSIANS
AND ALL OF A SUDDEN WE'RE GOING
TO ESCALATE ON THEIR FRONT DOOR.
I LIKE THE IDEA -- THIS IS A
PROXY WAR RIGHT?
PROXY WAR RIGHT ON THEIR
DOORSTEP, I GET IT, THAT'S WHERE
WE ARE NOW, BUT THE JET THING
SEEMS A LITTLE RISKY.
AND I'M NOT READY TO SAY, HEY,
BIDEN, YOU'RE COMMANDER IN
CHIEF, YOU'RE IN CHARGE, I TRUST
YOU.
THIS IS NOT A GUY I TRUST TO
MANAGE THIS TYPE OF DELICATE
DEAL WITH THE RUSSIANS WHO ARE
DESPERATE RIGHT NOW.
>> Dana: THE OTHER THING IS,
EARLIER TODAY WE WERE TOLD THAT
THERE WAS FRUSTRATION THAT THIS
DECISION MAKING WAS STUCK AT THE
WHITE HOUSE AND WE ASKED THE
ADMIRAL ABOUT THAT AND HE SAID,
NO, NO, NO, EVERYTHING'S FINE.
CLEARLY NOT EVERYTHING IS FINE
GERALDO IF THE POLS SAID OKAY WE
WILL FORCE YOUR HAND AND SEND
THESE
>> Geraldo: I THINK THE WHOLE
IDEA IN THEORY IS FINE AND NOBLE
AND SOUNDS LIKE IT WOULD BE
OBJECTIVE AND ANSWER OUR
NAGGING, YOU KNOW, GUT WRENCHING
FEELING THAT WE'RE ALLOWING THE
UKRAINIANS TO BE PUMMELED FROM
THE AIR BY THE RUSSIAN AIR
SUPERIORITY BUT I DON'T SEE IT
HAPPENING.
MECHANICALLY WHAT DO YOU DO?
SEND THE UKRAINIAN PILOT TO
GERMANY, THEN YOU'VE GOT TO
CHECK THEM OUT.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THEY CAN
INTEGRATE THE POLISH
INSTRUMENTATION WITH THE
UKRAINIAN AIR DEFENSES.
>> Dana: THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED IN
WORLD WAR II
>> Geraldo: IN WORLD WAR II IT
HAPPENED BUT IT TOOK A LONG TIME
AND EUROPE IS STILL MAD AT US
FOR TAKING SO LONG TO GET
INVOLVED AND ENGAGED.
I LIKE THE IDEA IN THEORY, I
JUST DON'T SEE IT.
I AGREE WITH JESSE ABOUT THE
NEED TO BE MEASURED AND NOT
PROVOKE, YOU KNOW, A WOUNDED
LION THERE.
ONE QUICK THING ABOUT ZELENSKYY
AND HIS SAFETY.
I THINK ZELENSKYY IS ALREADY
IMMORTAL.
HE'S ALREADY LEONITIS OR
CHURCHILL.
THEY CAN'T KILL HIM.
EVEN IF THEY DO HE WILL LIVE ON
FOREVER.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
POKING PUTIN, HE'S MADE HIS
POINT, BEEN VERY FLAMBOYANT AND
NOW I WANT HIM TO KEEP SAFE.
>> Dana: JUDGE YOU HAVE A
PENSIVE LOOK ON YOUR FACE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I HAVE TO TELL
YOU US HAS ALWAYS TAKEN THE LEAD
WITH NATO AND I THINK, YOU KNOW,
TAKE THIS IS VERY COMPLICATED.
BUT I ALSO THINK THAT IF POLAND
IS WILLING TO GIVE, YOU KNOW,
THE MIGS TO THE UKRAINIANS, AND
THAT OUR JOB WOULD BE TO BACK
FILL, WHAT IS THE PROBLEM?
AND YOU MENTIONED IT GERALDO AND
I THROW THIS OUT FOR DISCUSSION
ONLY, WITH UKRAINIANS GETTING
THAT PLANE FROM POLAND OR FROM
GERMANY?
AND FLYING IT?
I MEAN, THESE -- WE'RE WATCHING
THE MASSACRE OF A NATION AND
CHILDREN -- THIS IS CAN
BALANCEISM WHAT'S GOING ON.
IT'S TERRORISM
>> Geraldo: I AGREE WITH YOU.
>> Judge Jeanine: THIS IS MID
EVIL.
SO, WHOA, WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THEY KNOW HOW TO THREW I THE
PLANE.
BALONEY.
LET THEM -- IF WE CAN GET THE
PLANES TO THEM -- MAKE NO
MISTAKE, PUTIN IS GOING TO
CHANGE THE RULES AT EVERY TURN.
IF YOU PROVIDE A PLANE, YOU'RE
PROVOKING US.
IF YOU DO THIS, YOU'RE PROVOKING
ME.
AT SOME POINT WE'VE GOT TO STAND
UP AND SAY WE'RE STRONGER THAN
YOU ARE YOU LITTLE --
>> WHAT IF HE FIRES A TACTICAL
NUCLEAR WEAPON?
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT'S THE
PROBLEM.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM.
AND WHAT IF WE LIKE KOWTOW SO HE
HAS NO INCENTIVE TO NOT DO IT.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO DO OUR
NUCLEAR EXERCISES BECAUSE WE
DON'T WANT TO INTIMIDATE HIM.
WE HAVE THE WRONG GUY IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Greg: I THINK THE OVERARCHING
MESSAGE IS WE SHOULD BE VERY
WEARY BASED ON MESSAGES COMING
OUT OF UKRAINE OR RUSSIA.
THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF WE HEAR
ABOUT THAT TURNS OUT TO NOT BE
TRUE.
THE MEDIA IS FRAMING THIS IN A
WAY THAT -- THIS ISN'T MY
ANALOGY THIS IS HOW I FEEL.
THAT UKRAINE IS LIKE THE CHILD
OF A DIVORCE AND THEY'RE
FIGHTING FOR CUSTODY, AND RUSSIA
IS THE BIOLOGICAL PARENT AND WE
ARE THE STEP MOM WHO DOESN'T
WANT THE ABUSIVE DAD TO GET HIM.
THAT MAY NOT BE AN ACCURATE
ANALOGY BUT THAT'S HOW I FEEL
THE NARRATIVE DYNAMIC IS GOING,
AND I SEE -- THIS IS WHAT I GIVE
CREDIT TO ZELENSKYY IS THAT THIS
IS THE OLD WORLD VERSUS THE NEW
WORLD.
PUTIN THINKS THE WORLD IS ONLY
ABOUT SEIZING LAND AND ZELENSKYY
UNDERSTANDS YOU'RE SEIZING MINDS
NOW.
HE'S FIGHTING A PERSUASIVE
BATTLE FOR MINDS AND I CAN
CANNING PUTIN'S BUTT ON THIS.
WHETHER THE STUFF ZELENSKYY IS
SAYING IS TRY, IT'S POSITIVELY
TRUMPIAN.
I LOVE ZELENSKYY THE WAY THE GUY
WHO FEEDS HIM PELLETS BECAUSE
I'M IN A INDUSTRY WHERE I LOVE
GETTING THE PELLET EVERY DAY.
BUT YOU HAVE TO WONDER WHEN
YOU'RE LISTENING WHETHER THESE
PELLETS ARE REAL OR NOT WHETHER
WE'RE BEING ARTIFICIALLY PULLED
INTO A CONFLICT, RIGHT, THROUGH
THIS DAVID AND GOLIATH NARRATIVE
THAT WE'RE GIVEN
>> Geraldo: BUT IT'S TRUE
>> Greg: MAYBE IT IS.
MAYBE IT IS.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S NOT TRUE.
BUT I'M SAYING YOU HAVE TO BE
AWARE OF WHAT'S TRUE VERSUS WHAT
STANDS OUT.
EVERY DAY PLANES LEAVE EVERY
SECOND OF THE DAY.
THE ONLY THING THAT STANDS OUT
IS WHEN A PLANE CRASHES.
SO WE LIKE THE STUFF THAT STANDS
OUT TO BE REPORTED BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY REPRESENTATIVE OF
REALITY.
WE HAVE TO ASK OURSELVES EVERY
DAY ARE WE BEING MANIPULATED
INTO ENTERING A WAR THAT WE
SHOULD BE NO PART OF IT AND I
RESENT ANYBODY SAYING YOU MUST
BE PRO RUSSIAN OR PRO PUTIN.
NO, I'M PRO AMERICAN
>> Geraldo: YOU HAVE TO BELIEVE
YOUR EYES
>> Greg: I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD
GET INVOLVED
>> Geraldo: GETTING INVOLVED
GIVING THEM EVERYTHING THEY
POSSIBLY NEED THAT WE HAVE --
LIKE THE JAVELIN, THE STINGERS,
THE OTHER SHOULDER FIRED
MISSILES.
KNOCKING HELICOPTERS AND
AIRCRAFT AND RUSSIANS OUT OF THE
SKY.
IF THE STORY IS TRUE THAT DAVID
IS NOW MUS TERRING HIS STRENGTH
AND TAKING ON GOLIATH
SUCCESSFULLY AND CONVOYS ARE
STALLED AND TANKS ABANDONED AND
CREW